how's it going red my name is Pippa I've
been refreshing the [ __ ] page for
like a half an hour Jesus Christ
you brothers keep being away one more
happy wheels it's not that [ __ ] easy
when you can't play the game all right
what the [ __ ] is this all right okay
oh [ __ ] all right that's called Oh what
am I doing here
ha cha cha ha ha oh my gosh but but keep
going but my dad got my purse a do it
let it go baby I don't give a [ __ ]
come on babe Rose come on man ha ha
I feel like I'm a [ __ ] Chuck Norris
somehow it makes that doctor that's
right come at me no and I'm just kidding
if not no alleged a backflip sword stop
wha come here that's not racist he came
at me why am I having new tail all right
have a guy come at my brother
nice try come on me Timmy that's right
come on me grabs that's right come on
mate this is not racist what is he doing
thanks for playing thank you for making
that I'm happy now another escape huh
I'm in it have a lot [ __ ] I'm alive
I'm alive
hey you're like look at my leg look at
my leg all right
escaping yeah now you stop it hard got
have it all right can do this I can feel
it calm man
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
expect that turn your volume down it'll
get loud
alright must whoa holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] no wait for me guys right now all
right
back flip there we go there we go
come on baby nice shut-eye my leg my leg
oh it's back [ __ ] me here we go there we
go lunch
gosh out of a fog
my leg by oh come on come I'm on a snail
[ __ ] have a snail
Thomas nah [ __ ] ya darlin how could you
do this to me but hello hello she's
slipping ah hello bitter [ __ ] I got
your boobies you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got your bow [ __ ] [ __ ] I got off
that's it hard-ass right [ __ ]
it's my liquids hello
whoa spooky [ __ ] Oh No so scary
I can turn up the volume a little bit
oh [ __ ] what that sound is just so
[ __ ] terrible sorry an elephant is
coming her oh [ __ ]
all right now so it is a ma ma ma ma
yeah
Jace's Christ I was lied all right mr.
Schad where you going nice [ __ ] you ah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] your mama that's right
my arm is now [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
all right breads don't even worry about
it I totally know what I'm doing let's
get up get up and get oh hey what's
going on down here guys
Oh shut shut the [ __ ] up okay all right
whoa oh oh [ __ ] me that's BA best man
hey man come back here I love you yes
best but you came back yeah [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me I Caleo best but I'll go come here
and [ __ ] me don't even worry about it no
I want to see what happened if you jump
here come on [ __ ] you come on there we
go
that was [ __ ] annoying and not worth
it unicorns third sword throw the [ __ ]
is this I don't like that hard pone but
I like those boobies down there
here you go boobies you're in a card
ah your tract back what the [ __ ]
purple that's gay chain reaction I see
what you did there
oh it's another one of these alright
let's try this
[ __ ] you love his arms ain't no pot like
a pretty pop party
fist pump yeah yeah [ __ ] judge the
short [ __ ]
oh no whatever am i popping oh yeah the
circle fact and then the crying in the
bed fat all right
[Music]
dad dad can you swing your sword why of
course
[Music]
all right I can swing my side what's the
pointless [ __ ] map I can do it with
one hand Dreamlands quest sorry there
was a problem
dreamland square sorry dreamland sorry
dreamland dreamland all right I Love You
Man
I love cami I want to [ __ ] what the
hell you were done as [ __ ] Kirby's here
Jace is kite what the [ __ ]
alright he's flying dammit I have to
read text because otherwise people will
be like repairs damage King did a dead
chase after him [ __ ] you [ __ ]
Kevin drugs are you on anyway alright
you should kill people
Paul is wrong we should make love to
each other's butt holes that is not OK
there you little [ __ ] oh the [ __ ] I
darkside like you I don't your mama's
[ __ ] not good enough I got bored
ah don't remind me all right what do we
got here ah shut - then kill you what do
you want oh it's a boss battle alright
whoa
alright what else [ __ ] you
[ __ ] yo don't [ __ ] me apples okay you
can [ __ ] me a bus god damn it I gotta
redo all this alright and then we go
back don't kill me
attack [ __ ] no attack [ __ ]
that's why are you crying haha come in
King dad I do too
mount dee dee da da doo doo dee dee what
the [ __ ] do you want
back off alright don't attack me I don't
like this I came so far away yes nice
going what out the [ __ ] you are thank
you
you have saved me from the demon spawn
I'm forever in your debt
all right can we I need more speed for
this one alright
far jamie oliver's person he doesn't
have one does he whatever what am i
doing down here
[Applause]
branch flip I actually said it right is
that our hit alright anyways [ __ ]
long as map every what do you want what
do you want okay
fatality I guess oh now we got a wrestle
King dad I do to dieter
alright King dad Jace's crisis master
[ __ ] luck alright dad I need to do to
come at me bro
don't you dare throw on that day mess me
[ __ ]
Miss Smith Balki you got mail fine J
subscribe get off my face what did you
do to them
alright let's get back in the ring all
right what else King dad i doo doo dee
dee [ __ ] you King data doo dee dee dee
that's right right in your deck another
one huh mess me [ __ ] don't throw it at
mess me [ __ ] haha alright
okay
ah God dang nah I don't
yeah I don't hang sure there's again I
love doing that alright I got